a deadly attack outside the Russian
Capital has many people wondering about
a possible link to the war in Ukraine a
bomb destroyed a car owned by a
prominent advisor to Russian President
Vladimir Putin over the weekend the
advisor's daughter TV commentator Daria
dugina was killed in the explosion
Charlie dagada has more from Ukraine
cell phone videos said to show the
Fireball from the car bomb on the
outskirts of Moscow dead at the scene
Daria dugina daughter of influential
Ultra nationalist Alexander Duggan an
outspoken supporter for the war in
Ukraine Kiev quickly denied
responsibility the president's office
saying unlike Russia we are not a
terrorist State the target is believed
to have been Dugan himself a man often
described as Putin's brain it does sound
as if Mr Putin is following your
blueprint he spoke with 60 Minutes
Leslie Stahl in 2017 about his book
promoting Russian expansionism including
the annexation of Ukraine he a little
bit disappoints us because it's it take
too long uh so but he did the first
steps first step in the 17 years the
attack has escalated tensions in the
run-up to Ukraine's Independence Day on
Wednesday and six months since stunned
ukrainians heard this sound for the
first time
and there go the air raid sirens it's
just another indication that although
the city seems normal nobody's running
to the shelters this city this country
is still in a state of war the Central
Square in Kiev has become a trophy case
of Russian tanks and armored vehicles
captured or destroyed in combat now
climbing frames for kids and backdrops
for selfies
president zielinski has warned that
Russia might be planning something
particularly nasty to spoil Independence
Day celebrations in Revenge six months
after trying to capture the capital
itself probably not the Victory Day
Parade President Putin had hoped for for
CBS mornings Charlie dagada Keith